les insolites de Véronique c'est à ces
informations qui vous ont peut-être
échappé dans le département des
informations qui sortent de l'ordinaire
c'est chaque mardi dans le 7 8 et on
commence Véronique avec ce qui est
peut-être moins un insolite plutôt on va
dire un coup de cœur aujourd'hui que
vous voulez nous faire partager c'est un
coup de cœur sur les
okomiyakis ou les takoyaki je sais pas
si je prenais bien je sais pas si on
prononce le S final d'ailleurs moi non
plus mais on parle de street food à
Versailles
vous allez partir directement au fin
fond du Japon et pouvoir déguster de la
street food parce que c'est vraiment de
la base sont pas des sushis ça n'a rien
à voir et en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que Vincent vicholas il est en
amoureux du Japon un amour de la cuisine
c'est un yvelinois il a il s'est offert
un beau voyage au Japon et il est allé
surtout à osakaï Kyoto il a découvert
cette street food où il raffole et il
s'est dit j'ai pas possible que je
rentre en France sans pouvoir les
confectionner moi-même puisque je n'en
trouverai pas ailleurs donc voilà il
s'est dit faut que j'apprenne à les
faire donc il s'est lié d'amitié avec un
jeune chef japonais qui avait un stand
de rue qui heureusement était anglophone
et qui a fini par lui lui donner ses
recettes parce qu'il faut des recettes
très précise évidemment des ingrédients
aussi bien précis et alors je peux vous
dire que takoyaki c'est en fait tacos ça
veut dire poulpe il y a qui c'est qui se
cuit sur plaque et économiyakis c'est
force au tofu cette espèce de grosse
galette blinis au chou avec de l'oeuf de
la levure soit du porte du tofu enfin
bref après non mais c'est vraiment super
bon c'est léger c'est c'est des goûts
qu'on connaît pas donc c'est quand même
je trouve bien bien sympathique de
pouvoir découvrir une cuisine vraiment
nouvelle parce que ça c'est alors les
gens qui se passionnent pour le Japon
qui sont à l'école connaissent bien
évidemment et ça leur manque donc voilà
la bonne adresse Vincent vous accueille
soit pour prendre de la acheter de la
nourriture à emporter soit pour déguster
sur place donc il est au cœur de
Versailles 63 avenue de Saint-Cloud et
il y a aussi des mots-chi glacés puis
petit à petit va ouvrir la carte
l'élargir un petit peu il travaille sur
les doriasis qui sont comme vous le
savez des desserts ou haricots rouges
et dai Suki le nom de son restaurant ça
veut dire j'aime beaucoup où je t'aime
beaucoup
alors là c'est une belle transition pour
la prochaine
sujet on parle de Saint-Valentin la
Saint-Valentin pour vous c'est une fête
commerciale ou ça vous tient à cœur la
Saint-Valentin Michael
en fait commercial également bon en tout
cas on peut la fêter de manière insolite
et le soir de la Saint-Valentin si on
veut de l'insolite en tout cas il faut
aller du côté de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
complètement il faut même aller plus
précisément au musée Maurice Denis
imaginez-vous parce que il propose en
fait de passer sa Saint-Valentin de
façon insolite vraiment insolite en
prenant des cours de bachata qu'est-ce
que c'est que la bachata c'est une danse
enfin vous savez peut-être ça m'évoque
tout de suite l'Amérique latine ça vient
de République Dominicaine si ça il y a
des influences de meringuer de boléro de
salsa enfin alors c'est une danse qui
est très surtout réputée pour son côté
sensuel langoureux au fond du lait voilà
c'est chaleureux c'est une bonne mise en
ambiance pour une soirée agréable de
Saint-Valentin éventuellement et donc
ils sont au musée je sais que vous en
parlerai mais bon il faut aller quand
même prévenir déjà à l'avance de
Mathilde Franco qui a testé les cours de
bachata on retrouvera le reportage jeudi
sur TV
moi je voulais quand même prévenir les
gens les téléspectateurs qu'il faut
s'inscrire qu'il y a pas 50000 places
que ça dure donc deux heures j'ai dit de
19 à 21h et donc bah écoutez vous avez
une semaine pour pour préparer vos
déchets et
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez du déhanché
de Mathilde ça fait cadre
dans le sang
depuis quelques années il me semble
voilà mais en tout cas c'était une
découverte pour elle mais on aura
l'occasion de découvrir avec elle
alors au-delà des informations sur vous
vous retrouvez aussi sur TV 78 pour
votre émission vyb qui donc mettons en
avant les personnalités yvelinoises de
ce territoire ce beau territoire des
Yvelines vous avez parlé de quoi
dernièrement et est-ce que vous en avez
des nouveaux prévu la prochaine
dernièrement j'ai parlé du musée
Lambinet c'est réouvert après trois ans
de travaux donc j'étais avec Émilie
maison neuve qu'elle a directrice et le
LM qu'on dise le conservateur du
muséuminé entre autres et elle nous a
présenté donc les nouvelles
scénographies les nouvelles pièces il y
a des nouveaux objets qu'on voyait pas
qui sont mis en valeur différemment il y
a plein d'ateliers aussi proposés j'ai
l'impression c'est la nouvelle mode à
des musiques qui proposent plein
d'ateliers d'interactivité pour faire
venir le public c'est très bien et
et du coup ben voilà c'était avec elle
et le extrait peut-être de ce
on va regarder tout de suite
au musée Lambinet regardez
moi je suis plutôt spécialisé oui en
mobilier en architecture plus donc
évidemment naturellement je me suis
plutôt intéressé à cette partie là mais
c'est surtout que ces œuvres-là étaient
plutôt des fervaloirs autrefois et pas
vraiment des œuvres d'art à part entière
et on voulait les mettre vraiment en
avant donc là harpe de naderman là le
liquide de Marie-Antoinette est vraiment
exposé très en valeur dans le salon doré
elle a bénéficié surtout d'une
restauration son mécanisme fonctionne à
nouveau on peut en jouer on en a joué
lors de lors du vernissage la reine la
réouverture en fait pour la réouverture
donc on est en train d'échanger les bons
plans sur le Japon
on pourra profiter de cette gastronomie
la japonais la street food et japonaise
du coup Vy P là qu'on retrouve bien sûr
en intégralité sur TV 78.com ça c'était
au musée Lambinet il y en a eu un autre
aussi tout récemment un autre qui était
ici même qui avec Bérengère Philippon
alors Bérengère Philippon elle est
maintenant
coach en nutrition elle s'intéresse
depuis quelques années elle est venue
hyper Calais elle a déjà fait trois
livres là les deux derniers viennent de
sortir sur une alimentation saine en
limitant l'indice glycémique voilà c'est
igba donc son premier livre c'était
recette
igba recette salée donc là elle s'est
attaquée à recette si j'ai barre recette
sucrée ce qui est un vrai challenge
parce que pas de sucre dans le sud comme
on fait elle a plein de de moyens de
petits trucs de ruses et tout pour qu'on
y arrive et en même temps c'est
délicieux ce qu'elle propose voilà et
après elle a écrit un troisième livre
qui donne plus des clés c'est un peu
plus élargi ou bien être en général
alors comment comment se préparer
soi-même à changer éventuellement
d'alimentation être plus cool avoir une
psychologie positive ouais genre ouais
ben on peut mêler gastronomie aller un
petit peu diététique aussi derrière
le japonais c'est très léger bien sûr il
y a pas de sucre aussi on le retrouve
bien sûr sur tv78.com juste pour revenir
sur la bachata ça m'intéresse beaucoup
moi la bachata
l'italienne lover dans d'autres
émissions voilà sur une autre émission
sur le si on parlait sport on peut
danser alors c'est ce qui est drôle
c'est qu'on danse au milieu des œuvres
finalement
incroyable c'est que vous dansez au
milieu des peintures qui qui en fait
sont les
œuvres de l'exposition actuelle qui
s'appelle femme encore encore un autre
lien donc femme ce sont soit des des
sujets des femmes en sujet de d'oeuvre
de peinture soit des femmes artistes qui
ont qui ont exécuté ses œuvres voilà et
vous verrez des tableaux certains ont
été restaurés récemment donc on l'avait
pas vu depuis longtemps d'autres ont été
acquis aussi récemment vous l'avez déjà
dit tout à l'heure je crois peut-être
c'est pas bon c'est pas grave voilà donc
c'est vraiment original et magnifique
vous avez fait votre choix gastronomie
ou bachata faut les deux la gastronomie
la communication